c'est PNL ouais
que j'aime beaucoup parce que
disons que c'est une musique pour les
non initiés
disons que je suis d'autant plus attiré
que c'est une musique que je pourrais
jamais faire de ma vie donc ça me
paraîtrait loin donc très mystérieux
donc complètement adorable pourquoi vous
pourriez pas faire ça
j'ai pas du tout la même vie j'ai pas du
tout
[Musique]
à les entendre chanter bon ben
ils ont frôlé les qualités bon moi j'ai
été attiré par le vandalisme au moment
donné
mais ça a duré trois mois dans ma vie je
fais un peu de garde à vue vous aviez
fait quoi
en vandalisme
j'avais détruit un peu de
du matériel citadin
bon allez c'est l'heure du 10 c'est pas
de matériel public
[Musique]
aussi un langage une vocabulaire à champ
lexical
que je connais très peu c'est pour ça
aussi que ce groupe et cette musique
aussi me matière tant que je connais
plus
[Musique]
et puis c'est une musique très
mélancolique la musique d'aujourd'hui en
France en tout cas
est très très mélancolique peut-être que
on est en train de vivre une époque très
mélancolique ça c'est possible quand
même le reflet de ce qui se passe
c'est pour ça que j'aime tant ce
discours merci
je m'endors
et voilà je
[Musique]
je cours comme là
je sais pas du tout ce que ça
je vous remercie